Well
tasting, Cristian Cásseres greets you with his
new News Now program in Spanish.
Today marks the anniversary of the day that
the casinos in the Chinese city
of Macao closed. The largest betting center in the
world suspended its operations due to the
pandemic and thus also marked an omen.
of what would come for the city of las
vegas the framed hotels only
remained closed for 15 days after
the pandemic hit and to date
the gaming industry in the
chinese city has not been able to recover new
details reflect a drop of 61 4  % in
profit last month compared to
January of last year marked is still
under strict travel restrictions at
its borders and security regulations
are still in place in all hotels and
casinos
the countdown to
the first day of face-to-face classes continues
for cis students and I am crossing
pre-kindergarten to third grade on
March 1st students will return to
campus to finish the year  or school
under a hybrid education plan just
on Wednesday the school district
released its more than 200-page guide
in which it details the restrictions and
guidelines for teachers and students,
including the use of masks, the
distance from desks
, cleaning protocols and
air quality improvement system facilities
and with students returning to school the
city of las vegas is
hiring for the after school and
before school program known as safety
applicants must be 18 years of age or
older and can find the
job application at  the
city's website
the driver accused of running over and
killing the five cyclists in december
will have his preliminary hearing before a
judge today
jordi versión remains jailed without the
possibility of bail the prosecution
accuses him of driving his truck under the
influence  of methamphetamine when he
struck bicyclists on Highway 95
near search  light the judge will decide if
there is enough evidence to schedule
a trial against the defendant
a program to help girls
stay active and make new
friends registration for cross underground
is now open the program is virtual
and meets twice a week
after hours  from school and
coaches they put a
special program of exercises that they can do
at home the program starts in the
spring and is for eight weeks for more
information you can visit run lb point or
heretic
and we take a look at the temperatures
today they continue to be a day  very sunny
with winds from the north of the valley
now the highs for today will be in the
high sixties and winds are expected to
reach speeds of 40 miles per
hour or more during the day
temperatures will also drop to less than
what was recorded for the day  Yesterday I am
Cristian Cáceres with his own
informative here inflated in Spanish
Happy Thursday
[Music]